this week on wheel of science we're
talking higher dimensions so
get your 4d glasses on
what's up morpheus welcome to wheel of
science chuck
spin that wheel oh wow i i guess you
don't feel like talking this week
[Music]
and peta marie scott wants to know this
how do we know higher dimensions
exist if they do exist how many
may there be we do not know
for sure if higher dimensions exist but
what we do know is mathematically
we can describe in complete detail
zero dimensional space one-dimensional
space
two-dimensional space three-dimensional
that's the space we live in
four-dimensional space that's the space
time in which we live and mathematically
just add a dimension to get five six
seven eight nine
ten so the math takes us there
and so too then does our imagination so
since the math can accurately model the
1 2 3 and 4 dimensions does that
mean that it's equally as accurate for
dimensions 5 6 7 8 9
10 and on one of the great features of
mathematical models of reality
is that when you manipulate the mass in
a way
you're manipulating your understanding
of reality
and if a math can make a prediction if a
new equation makes a prediction
and if it's prediction is based on an
idea that is fundamentally true
then there's a good chance that
prediction can be verified by experiment
so we don't yet know how to access other
dimensions
but the day that happens we just invoke
the math
and these higher dimensions might even
seem familiar
to people who have studied the math that
got us there oh man so i'm gonna call my
travel agent
and my math teacher
all right neil you ready for another
question ready for another question spin
that wheel
[Music]
okay alex reynoso says this
can a creature from a higher dimension
interact with us
in our dimension great question if a
higher dimensional creature interacted
with us
it would manifest in highly peculiar
ways
think about it if we are ants on a sheet
of paper
living only within that two-dimensional
flat world and we take a
sphere and pass it through that sheet of
paper
what would that look like to the ant the
ant would say oh wait a minute there's a
dot
oh the dot just became a circle a small
circle oh the circle's growing
oh my gosh oh it got to a maximum size
oh now there's a circle shrinking
oh it's a dot again it disappeared oh my
gosh
that's how an ant would describe us
passing a hollow sphere
through the ants universe to
two-dimensional universe
so there would be things happening in
our space-time
that would defy common sense
and we just describe things popping in
and out of existence and behaving in
ways
that we don't completely understand even
if we can accurately describe it
yet to a higher dimensional being it's
clear and obvious what's going on
so 4d would totally change alien probing
if you know what i mean it turns out
that
if you look at a two-dimensional
creature and they're purely two
dimensions
that means their skin is just a line
outlining their innards so from a
three-dimensional view you can see their
entire
inner structure to a higher dimensional
being than us
they can see entirely inside of our
bodies
and so they wanted to operate they
wouldn't have to open up our skin they
just go straight in
accessing it from a higher dimension
once your appendix out they just go
step that's it you don't even know what
happened
that would be cool surgery in a higher
dimension would transform medicine
well that certainly makes a part of my
body very happy all right let's take a
little break right now and we'll be back
with
more wheel of science as i go off to get
probe by another dimension
this episode is sponsored by wix if you
need to build a website in any dimension
you gotta use wix drag and drop to build
the site of your dreams
we did it here for wheelofscience.com
add a blog
add a store have fun with animated
backgrounds we could actually
make the background of video you'll have
the perfect website for desktop
and mobile head to the link in the
description and start your site
using wix today that's wix.com
go slash star talk welcome back to wheel
of science of course we're here with dr
neil degrasse tyson neil you ready for
another question
bring it on spin that wheel
[Music]
richard stenhouse wants to know this how
can we know what a hypercube
is if we can't even conceive what it
looks like we can draw what it looks
like
and precisely describe every property
that it has
just because we can't make one just
because we don't have access to a fourth
dimension
doesn't mean we don't fully understand
what it is in the fourth dimension
the hypercube has sides
that are three-dimensional cubes
in the same way a three-dimensional cube
has sides
that are two-dimensional squares in the
same way that a square
has sides that are one-dimensional lines
in the same way a line has sides that
are
zero dimensional points
don't get me started look at that don't
put neal in a box
or a cube or a hypercube all right neil
so we received an episode comment from
john cates and he says this there's
probably a giant donut hurling at us
from the fifth dimension
fred's coming to kill us do you have any
idea what this guy's talking about
i see what you did there you called this
evil donut from space
fred because we don't really know what
it is and because i called
dark matter fred because we don't know
what it is we shouldn't even call it
dark matter because that implies we know
it's matter but we don't
and same with dark energy we don't know
if his anders
so fred and wilma that's really what you
should call dark matter and dark energy
so i see what you did there
so in that case can we call the donut
dino
hey it's time for this week's poll and
make sure you answer it right here and
here's the question
would you want to visit a higher
dimension full well knowing they'll make
fun of you for the way that you look
neil well imagine a 2d creature that
pops into existence in our 3d world
they'd be like paper people right they
would be flat
completely and then if they turn
sideways they would disappear
entirely they would have no thickness at
all so they could hide from you just
always making sure they stay
they stay sort of parallel to your line
of sight
so if you pop into a fourth dimension
people will laugh at you and they'll
poke you and wonder what's wrong with
you
because you're missing a dimension can
you handle that emotionally
i think that's the question now for me
yeah i take it
definitely put me in a higher dimension
well while you're there just make sure
they take out your appendix
that's the important thing hey what do
you know that is our show
as always we have to say thank you to dr
neil degrasse tyson thanks neil all
right chuck always good to be with you
and as you can see i'm in my office this
time but
sometimes i could be somewhere else in
the universe but you find me every time
that is because i am stalking you i went
through the trash last night
when we were looking for an online home
for wheelofscience.com
we went to wix yeah i built the site
myself and it took me
less time than it does to get into my
corset in the morning
don't judge me wix helps you get your
sights seen
their search engine optimization tool
guides you to internet domination
you can get a custom domain and more if
you upgrade to a premium plan
how cool is that head to the link in the
description and start your site today
that's wix.com go slash star talk
until next time i'm chuck nice and
thanks for watching wheel of science and
i'm your personal astrophysicist
as always bidding you to keep looking up
you